a military parade marking latvia's
independence from Russia
it's a show of strength as is this
military exercise in the Latvian
countryside after Russia's annexation of
Ukraine's Crimea region the small Baltic
nation fears that its independence is
once again under threat Crimea change
our thinking about our future because we
were very happy what we have but the
Crimea shows that we need more strong
army more money we should invest in
these capabilities and we should work
together with all NATO forces others in
Latvia is the largest military training
ground in the Baltics these Latvian
soldiers are training alongside Brits
Americans and other NATO troops only 150
miles away from the Russian border
Latvia with its capital Riga is a member
of both the European Union and NATO
recently Lafayette allies have increased
their military presence in the country
but for the foreign minister Russia
still feels too close for comfort we
have enormous kind of debate about the
budget about the taxation policy but
there is only one item in the budget law
that nobody disputes and that's the
defense budget we are not in panic we
are not fearing anything but are
cautious and in order to be really
assured we need this NATO presence on
the streets of Riga there's indignation
anger and concern like in Crimea ethnic
Russians make up almost 1/3 of the
Latvian population leaving it vulnerable
to Russian influence and the election of
Donald Trump who declared he would not
necessarily challenge putin's moves has
added to the concerns of Latvians we
don't know what putting things we don't
know what the Russia things we don't
know what the early thing so I mean it's
not it's definitely worse for us that
Trump was elected how much worse we
don't know I try to not think about this
but I hope everything will be ok which
we try to think for best we don't think
that Trump could be that stupid actually
it's likely and still believe that
being in NATO and being in European
Union it means something so we hope that
it will it will still mean that they
will no not like start a war why do
Americans need this war a propaganda war
is already underway with videos like
this one russian-speaking media is
broadcasting their messages into the
Baltics the Kremlin is using similar
hostile narratives in let's say in
Ukraine and in Moldova and partially
here in the Baltics just as well and
some of them are like this idea of
compatriot policy ROS c'mere or maybe
even Soviet nostalgia and and some of
like some of the ideas are also
federalizing this this a sovereign state
back on the training grounds just
outside of riga american paratroopers on
military exercises the message here
solidarity and deterrence latvia sees a
real threat from moscow and there is the
concern that that is a problem a US
president donald trump might not know
enough about and might not care enough
about so latvia and the other baltic
states are making preparations just in
case